[MUSIC PLAYING]
LORENA MUNOZ CUADRADO:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
ASIER ORBE: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
LORENA MUNOZ CUADRADO:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[APPLAUSE]
ASIER ORBE: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
LORENA MUNOZ CUADRADO:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
In the cloud, security
is about trust.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[APPLAUSE]
RAPHAEL COSTE:
Thank you very much.
Can you all hear me?
Yes, sounds fine.
What a great presentation.
Thank you very much.
And what a great platform.
We think at AODocs, it's
the best platform, at least
the most secured.
And that's why we chose to
build AODocs on top of it.
So what I'm going
to present you today
is how you can leverage
the G Suite and especially
Google Drive and AODocs to
build the right processes
in your company to make
it even more secure.
Just a quick word on who we are.
We are AODocs, an enterprise
document management solution.
I could say we are the
SharePoint of Google,
but if I am recorded
and if my boss hears
me compare myself to
SharePoint, I'll get in trouble,
because we're much, much
more better than SharePoint.
So we bring the typical
features of DMS to G Suite--
workflow, metadata
check-in/check-out,
advanced search,
version management.
And we are completely
integrated.
I'll discuss it a bit later.
We were created in 2012.
We are an American company based
in San Francisco, operating
in Atlanta, Paris, London,
Milano, Sydney, and New Delhi.
We have over 800
clients in the world
and over 2.4 million users
on the Google marketplace.
We are recommended
for G Suite, which
means we are completely aligned
in terms of vision and security
standards.
Regarding customers, so
that's to name a few.
We work both with the public
sector, the private sector.
We work with the cabinet
office in the UK,
so it's the Office of the
Prime Minister in the UK.
We work with the United Nations.
We work with many large
private companies,
manufacturing services.
We work with "The
New York Times."
They are the head of the AODocs
user group for North America.
Two clients I want to focus on.
One is Google.
Google is a client of AODocs
since July 2016 for 15,000
users.
And they use it across
different teams.
We work with the legal
department of Google
in Mountain View.
We work with the Data
Center Operations of Google.
And they use it to manage their
standard operating procedures
and how to change, for
instance, a diesel filter
on a data center.
And we work in
Spain with Cabify.
Great company.
We're very proud to work with
them, growing extremely fast,
and they have amazing
use cases for AODocs.
To sum it up and to give
you the big picture,
we consider Drive and Team
Drive are the best platforms
to store documents and
to share documents.
And we make it possible for
the different departments
across a company to build
vertical applications.
So we work a lot with IT to help
them migrate all their legacy
systems--
SharePoint, eRoom,
Alfresco, you name it--
to AODocs.
We work a lot with
the legal department
to help them manage the
lifecycle of their contracts,
HR, operations, marketing.
We'll see that a bit
later in the presentation.
I'm going to focus today
on how you can put in place
the right processes to make
your company even more secure.
And I'll start with the
reduction on human error
by automating the
sharing permissions.
AODocs has a workflow engine,
very powerful, very agile.
And you can set up
the right processes,
your business processes.
You can digitalize them
through the AODocs workflow.
And you can set the workflows,
such as for each step
of the workflow, the
right permissions
apply automatically
on the documents.
So instead of having
to decide manually,
who am I going to share
this document with,
you just create the
document directly in AODocs,
click on the Workflow
button, send for validation,
and the document will
be shared automatically
with the right people who
need to validate the document.
Also, you can use the
check-in/check-out to make sure
there is no concurring
edition on the documents.
So when you work on a
very important procedure,
for instance, and
you need to edit it,
you can check-out the documents.
So it's like if you took away
a document from the office
to your home, let's say, to
work on it, and you are sure--
you're guaranteed by AODocs--
that while you work
on this document,
no one else is working on it--
or at least they're not editing
it, they're just viewing it.
So with the workflow, the
advanced security managements
that we offer, and features
like check-in/check-out,
we drastically reduce the
human error of your documents.
I'll take an example of
the publication workflow.
Typically, when
you need to publish
a policy inside
your company, you
start to create
an initial draft.
So you don't need
the whole company
to access the draft, just you
and maybe a few colleagues.
Then you send it for approval.
Here, the permissions
need to change,
because you might
need to send it
to the legal or the
compliance department,
so that they make sure
the document is OK.
Then the document is published.
So it might going to be
published on your intranet.
And so in this case,
you want everybody
in the company to access it.
So AODocs will automatically
share the document
with the whole company.
Then after a certain period of
time, you have two choices--
either the procedure or the
policy needs to be updated.
So the version one of the
policy will stay updated.
You will create a draft of
a version two, work on it,
process the version two
through the same workflow.
And once the version
two is validated,
it will be published as well
and replace the version one.
After some time, if it's the
way you configured the workflow,
the document can be
automatically archived,
which is going to be the
case for the version one.
And so it's unshared
from the whole company
and shared to just a
restricted number of people.
So to sum it up, the
right permissions
are automatically applied at
each step of the workflow.
Now, why is it an
easy setup for you
and your company to apply the
right processes with AODocs?
First of all, there
is a very agile setup.
You don't count in
months or weeks.
You count in days.
Everything is
prepackaged in AODocs.
The workflow engine is
extremely intuitive.
Even myself can
configure a workflow.
And so you have templates.
If you want to work for
your legal department
to help them configure
the right application,
they can just take the legal
management template, copy it,
and it's set up in a
few days, which makes
it a very flexible platform.
And that's why we can work with
so many different departments.
Some of our clients use AODocs
as a ticketing platform.
Some others use it
for their compliance.
Some for their audit processes.
Some for their
quality departments.
And finally, it's very well
integrated with G Suite.
We don't store your documents.
The documents we manage are
stored on your Google Drive.
So in terms of
security, you're covered
by Google, which is, as you
just saw, extremely secured.
And in any case,
everything in AODocs
was built on the
Google Cloud Platform.
So the quality and the
security of the application
is guaranteed by Google.
We focused especially
on the permission--
on reducing the human
error on the permissions
on the documents.
Now, this is to cover the
confidential information,
but we can help you
protect yourself
from the different risks that
your businesses are exposed to.
Compliance risk, we have a
document retention module,
so that you can manage
your company policies.
That's what Whirlpool is
doing, for instance, worldwide.
They have more than
300 retention rules.
And they can define
them into AODocs
and apply them on
different AODocs libraries.
We can help you protect yourself
from the HR and legal risks
by helping you build the right
AODocs libraries to cover
yourself for internal audits,
incidents reporting, company
policies.
And we help you protect
from operational risks.
So incidents reporting again,
standard operating procedures,
and quality control.
Thank you very much.
Please come at the booth
if you want a live demo.
And you'll meet Maria,
Javier, Alessandro.
And we'll be more happy
to discuss with you
how you can transform
your business with AODocs.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]